do you and dixie talk about the future
like
is she you're oh you're smiling
i i have an idea of where that's going
is she
your forever person i could definitely
see myself marrying dixie and like
that's the
that's the goal right like i don't want
to be with someone if i'm not
if the intention is not to date it's not
miriam you know
that's so cute i i i think she's my
forever person
so 2021
is going to be a big year for you
because you have this new show coming
out
called noah beck tries things first of
all how did this show
come about yeah so awesomeness tv and i
uh
collaborated on this whole thing i
wanted to make it very
like a fun thing rather than just like
super scripted you know so i got a group
of
really cool people that i'm really good
friends with and
basically just put the cameras in front
of us did what they're really good at
and just kind of
had fun and i'm really excited and it
comes out january 22nd 7
a.m pacific time what is the craziest
thing
that you got to try for the show
i did makeup with james charles but like
i've done that
and like james is one of my best friends
right kenzie ziegler actually taught me
how
or was associated with
a coach who taught us how to salsa
so yeah we did some dancing so that was
really fun so you'll be seeing
i guess you'll have to see i mean i
i thought i caught on pretty quick but i
mean that's all up for
uh you guys to debate i guess larry
taught me how to rap
oh are you a better salsa dancer or
rapper
honestly i think salsa dancer i'm i'm
not
even though i love rap music i love like
just
freestyling just like i i mean i thought
i was like okay at it but then like
larry is like he's very
quick what did dixie teach you so you
would think she'd be teaching me how to
like sing and stuff like that because
she's an amazing artist
but um we tried to mix it up and we
thought it'd be a cute idea if she just
overall just raided my boyfriend
ability and like my boyfriend material
and so
that episode i basically
i don't want to spoil too much about it
but we went on a really cute date and we
did some cool things
and at the end she graded how good of a
boyfriend i was
so how how good of a boyfriend are you
do you think
i'd give myself an a a plus
yeah yeah i i think i try to do
everything
i just want her to be happy you know i
try to do everything to make her happy
and i always
i mean i put her first even sometimes
when i shouldn't put her first
um like when there's like work going on
i kind of like hold on like let me do
this
and i just go straight back to her and
so um
yeah i love her so that's what
it does to you right exactly when fans
watch this series what do you want them
to kind of
take away or to learn about you and your
personality aside from what we see on
tick tock and social media i want them
to see how
like just how how how much i actually
genuinely get along with these people
that were on
my show and so because
i mean i you'll be able to figure it out
but there was no so it was unscripted it
was really just
so everything's genuine everything's
like
real conversation and so i i mean
i guess you'll just be able to see how
how fun it was
just hanging out with friends in front
of a camera so yeah
you seem so excited just talking about
it i'm so excited like i can't really
and i i really hope people love it as
much as i love filming it
you talked about dixie a little bit
i'm just curious did you always have a
crush on her before you actually
got together you know what's so funny i
would say
march of yeah march of 2020 honey i
made a i actually posted because it came
up on my snapchat memories
and it was like a filter where i was
like what tic toc like what tick tock uh
what tick tocker has a crush on you and
like in my dorm room just laying down
like a
college soccer player just in my bed
just
kind of going through it and it landed
on dixie and i was like
no way i kind of gave a face like i
always thought she was obviously very
beautiful
and like when i first joined i think the
first person i followed was charlie
because like
duh like yeah that's like yeah yeah it's
you that's it has to be like the first
follow right so
when i first downloaded six i followed
charlie and then there was this one
video where like
she introduced dixie as like her sister
and i realized that dixie was more like
uh like it was just it was crazy because
i
obviously she was very beautiful and
but i i just never thought i would have
a chance like i was like
i'm here in portland like in a dorm room
she's in la
like doing crazy stuff so i was like
i'm not gonna even like stress about it
but then i did that tick tock thing and
then it came up and i posted on tick
tock and people like this is insane like
this is manifestation
like you really spoke it into existence
and i'm like
i really did but so yeah no she was
definitely
she was definitely a tic-tock crush of
mine so that's great
you did mention i mean before you sort
of blew
up on tick tock in your own right i mean
you had a college scholarship do you
ever want to go
back to college yeah which is crazy so
i was living the dorm life uh i had a
full ride scholarship to the university
of portland for soccer
uh d1 so like that's all i knew growing
up was soccer all i wanted to be it was
a professional soccer player and
asked my parents like when i was three
years old i was playing soccer like and
i'd like to think i was on the right
track i had trials set up in europe
uh in like a few different countries
this summer like the past summer and but
kobet hit
and i wasn't able to travel so that kind
of
it was a bummer but also like i mean
everything happens for a reason i guess
i mean
it was the hardest decision i've ever
had to make stop playing soccer but
i mean it's it seems like everything's
working out right now so i'm kind of
just rolling with it
and i don't regret anything
i'm very happy with what i'm doing now
and the people i'm
surrounded with but could i see myself
going back to college probably not just
because
schooling wasn't like
i didn't go to this sounds bad but i
didn't go to college for school right
i went to college soccer i wanted to do
like one or two years and then
get out as soon as i could totally just
start
my professional career like that was a
goal but yes
and especially because i've gotten paid
as an uh as an ncaa athlete you aren't
allowed to get paid
like by the likeliness of your name
though i would not be able to go back
and play soccer
oh that's crazy like you just can't play
professionally now
no i could play i could go and play
professionally oh okay
if i like really really wanted to and
like
trained obviously like i'd shake the
rest off i could go back to play
i could go pro but i couldn't go play
college i couldn't go back to college
because of
the ncaa rules are we going to see you
up here
on charlie and dixie's reality show
um possibly that's kind of uh
in discussion right now just okay
i think uh you may or may not see me
we'll keep it at that okay it's kind of
crazy though you guys are all getting
your own
shows do you guys ever just like sit
around and talk about like whoa this
life is pretty freaking amazing
yeah no that's the thing like people
people don't realize like
we're just kid like we're kids and like
i'm still 19 years old like i'm just
a kid trying to figure things out and
like
um i've been blessed with amazing
opportunities and it's like
yeah you kind of need that time to like
think back like what is happening
and like obviously i'm super grateful
for everything
but at the end of the day we are just
kids and so people always just like
flood our comment section with like oh
you don't deserve this like you you
didn't work for this and it's like
what like it gets frustrating like
that's why i don't really look at them
anymore and i'm kind of numb to it where
it's like
i'm just gonna do what makes me happy
because at the end of the day like
life's too short to just like worry
about other people
and like what they think it is crazy
because i mean i've talked to
charlie about this too like the amount
of
bullying that i think i talked to bonnie
about this too it's like there's a lot
of
haters and there's a lot of people who
sit behind their computers and they say
whatever they want to say
i mean how do you sort of ignore all of
that
and like you have a message to those
people i guess i mean
really just no matter what i say people
are always going to have something to
say
i i i i don't take any of it personally
because
they don't know me personally personally
so that's why i just don't take it like
that because
i i like to think if you were to get to
know me personally like if any of these
people
saying these rude things about me and
others like if they were to get to know
us personally they'd realize that we're
just kids
and that we're i mean quite enjoyable
people to be around
i like to believe and like i like to set
myself with people that i enjoy being
around as well so i'd like to think that
all my friends
are good like kind-hearted people and
so i mean at the end of the day like
i don't know i there's not much to say
to those kind of people i just feel bad
like yeah that they're taking the time
out of their day to write that stuff
but it is what it is
do you and dixie talk about the future
like
is she you're oh you're smiling
i have an idea of where that's going is
she you're forever person are you too
young to even think that way
um things seem very serious is all
yeah and like obviously a lot of that's
the internet like sure just
take it so quickly we've only been
dating for i mean it hasn't been four
months and four months is coming up but
it's
um it seems so much longer it seems so
much longer right and
and like your fans start to build like
this like connection with you guys and
like oh
like we love them together um but yeah
no
i could definitely see myself marrying
dixie and like that's the
that's the goal right i got i mean
i say this at this age like you want a
date to marry but we're also 19 where
it's
we are still young but i mean i don't
know that's just how i am like i don't
want to be with someone i don't want to
waste my time like i don't want to be
with someone if i'm
not if the intention is not to date it's
not miriam you know
that's so cute oh yeah i i
i think she's my forever person so
you